(water pouring)
(bass guitar)
(phone notifications)
(upbeat funk)
- A little nervous, a little nervous...
(all agreeing)
- A little nervous, but it's okay.
Ooh.
- Hi.
I'm Mabel, I'm 22.
I'm originally from Nashville, Tennessee.
No hard feelings.
Thanks for staying.
- [One Of The Men] Thanks for having us.
(upbeat Latin music)
- I don't bite.
- Oh okay bet!
How can we open that bottle?
- We should have Mabel do it.
- Oh no, I hate popping
bottles of champagne
it scares me every time.
- You got it.
- Shake it up a little bit too.
(all laughing)
- [Jether] Aye yo, hold
on, hold on, I'm in range.
- [Ryan] Rip it off.
(all surprised)
- [Ryan] There we go!
- [Mabel] Oh, thank you!
- You know what I'm saying?
Tell me when to stop.
- [Man To Far Left] What'd
you get your degree in?
- Journalism.
- [Man To Far Left] Oh, wow.
- Yeah, I work in influencer strategy.
- How old are you guys?
Wait, yeah.
- 23.
- 21.
- 22.
- Uh huh.
- Old enough.
(all laughing)
- Oh shit, okay.
- My boy funny.
- 20.
- 23.
- Okay.
I really like museums, I like art.
- [Sound From Video]
Okay, I like it, Picasso.
- I like music a lot.
- What music you listen to?
- I really like Brockhampton,
but other artists I listen to ,
I have my teeny bop, like
I have One Direction.
I love One Direction.
And if you don't you
should probably just leave.
I like Harry styles, obviously.
- I'm a big fan, I like Harry Styles.
- I'm a Zayn fan.
- David? Uh, no we love
Zayn, Zayn's great!
I have a record player,
and I have jazz music.
So I like Louis Armstrong.
- I have a whole record player
and a Louis Armstrong record.
- He's great.
In high school I would
get to school early,
this is so nerdy,
and sit there and listen to jazz music
if I had an exam or something
and get my mind in the space
and be like, "Let's go Mabel."
- Can you tell us a little
bit about your fashion sense?
Like you seem super stylish, I
see the boots and the jacket.
- Thank you!
- Very cool.
- The past year I hated my
clothing, 'cause I did go
to a Southern school where
it was sorority girls
and everything, which wasn't my style.
So then once I finally left
that bubble, I was like,
all right, I need to find some
dope ass pieces of clothing.
And so I kind of go
for an edgier look now.
I really like black.
I really like leather.
I'm into skater boys and skate culture and
the good that skate culture
does for communities.
But that was a really nice question.
Thank you.
- Craziest college experience.
- Crazy...
- Oh, that's a question.
(all laughing)
- Me and my friend Emily
actually stayed up till 7:00 AM
because we wanted to wait for
the McDonald's chicken biscuits,
which they don't have here,
which was to my surprise, devastating.
- I was like, what's a chicken biscuit.
- Oh my God...
(all laughing)
- It's chicken in a biscuit.
We both fell asleep in my bed
eating our chicken biscuits.
- What would your previous relationships
say is the best part of your personality?
- Like what I've learned from
my previous relationships?
- Yeah, sure.
- I think I've learned to
just be really independent.
I think the past guys that I've been with,
I just learned that I can't count on them.
- Oh, that sucks.
- And, yeah, but not in
a bad way, in a way that
made me realize I can only
really count on myself
and I stopped dating guys and
everything for like a year,
and now I'm in that space
where I'm like, okay,
I'm ready to be independent,
but I'm ready to
have someone be independent with me.
- [Man To Far Left] Yeah.
- And we can rule the world.
That's what I want.
- [One Of The Men] That's wonderful.
- That codependency is
like an anchor sometimes.
- I feel like you should be
able to be independent together.
We can be able to go out
together, but also I have my group
of friends, and you don't
need me, and vice versa.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
- Right, for sure.
- Ryan and Mabel.
- What?
- You were chopping it,
you were like, "So, like..."
You were like...
(all laughing)
- I was like, yo, damn, their connection.
I'm like, ah, man, I'm
definitely gonna lose.
So I started drinking my cup.
- Craziest college experience?
I've had a lot of, I mean,
going to a Southern school...
(all laughing)
- I'm giving it to Ricky though.
I think they had that
little music connection.
I was like, I was like, "Oh, okay".
- Jazz, I mean.
- Oh jazz.
- I mean, I'm gonna give
it to my man right here,
like, bruh, if she
doesn't pick you, I will.
(all laughing)
- Let's see.
(lowkey music)
(all laughing)
- Bro, put it to your body,
'cause you can look at it.
(laughing)
You can see the name.
- Is my handwriting that bad?
I'm trying not to, like...
- Sorry dog.
- No, I mean, I didn't
talk much, that's on me.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm good.
- [Ryan] I'm gonna shake your hand.
- [Mabel] Oh, another handshake.
Oh, I like your rings!
- This is a pretty surreal experience.
- How are you?
- Nervous. Anxious. Mesmerized by you.
- Oh, thank you.
- Okay.
- Were you in a fraternity?
- I was.
- I could tell.
I kinda feel like, the way you
popped the bottle of champagne.
- So, I wanted to know what
your best pick-up line is.
- Oh God.
I would definitely compliment
someone on their outfit first.
I like your outfit actually,
I like the shoe lace,
that's cool, I've done
that before, like the...
- Yeah I didn't have a belt today,
I was like...
- The shoe lace! I thought
about that too, with these!
- What's your zodiac sign?
(laughing)
- I'm a Virgo.
- Ooh, she's...
- What about you?
- She's meticulous.
I get a lot of hate, I'm a Gemini.
- Oh.
- I'm never gonna be
the person that's like,
no, I'm not dating you
'cause you're a Gemini,
except Aquariuses.
- I don't know if I sit down,
you know, I'm an Aquarius.
- You're the Aquarius!?
I heard them all giggling.
- You shot me in the heart, it hurt.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- I was gonna say, also, I like how
your necklace kind of
matches your eye color.
- Oh, thank you!
- Did you do that yourself,
or do you get them done?
- Oh, I do them myself.
- Can you do mine please? I need help.
- I totally got you.
I got you, I can.
- Thank you.
- Let me see your nails.
- My what?
- Your nails.
- Oh, my nails.
I painted them myself, please don't
look at them for too long.
- What? You did a good job, you did aight.
- No, they look kind of
stupid, but thank you.
- We gonna get you right, it's fine.
- What about you? Do you
have any career goals?
- I work, as I said,
in influencer strategy.
I think that there is a future to
that whole realm of social media
which a lot of people, I
feel like, look down upon.
There's people out there
that are influencers
that do a lot of damage,
but then there's a lot of them who are
smaller followings that
are amazing people...
- Yeah definitely.
- And get really good resources out there.
- Yeah, no, I think that's wonderful.
Like you're really trying
to spread good vibes...
- Yeah!
- And the message, I vibe with that.
- So what do you plan to
do after you graduate?
- I wanna get into the cadet program
to officially become a firefighter.
So once I'm there, kind of
work towards those goals.
- I volunteered with helping
and rehabilitating sea lions.
- I love animals.
I wanted to be a vet when I was younger,
I was like, I want to be
around animals all the time.
- I definitely want to cut out
meat for the animal reason.
- I was vegetarian for
two years in high school.
- Really?
- I saw this documentary, it's called
If Slaughter Houses Had Glass
Walls, and I was traumatized.
And so I refused meat, and
then I had Chick-fil-a,
and then I was like, ah!
I miss meat.
But, yes, I would love to get
to a point where I could
be vegan at some point.
- I know a really good vegan spot
where they have vegan tacos and burritos.
- Oh!
- Around OC.
- That sounds pretty ideal.
- It's probably the best
place to go on it first date.
- Okay.
- But what are you into?
- I love movies.
- Ooh, my dad gone like you.
- Name your number one movie.
- Any Leonardo DiCaprio movie.
(laughing)
- I love LA LA Land.
- Oh my god, LA LA Land's so good.
- The jazz, especially,
I know you're into jazz.
- I am into jazz.
- I actually know how to
play one of their songs.
- No way.
- Yeah, so I could serenade you.
- Yeah!
- Yeah. What do you think the
right age is to have a kid?
- My parents got married at like 28.
I wanna live my life a little,
and then have that companion,
and travel together, and then get married,
and then start a family
in my thirties and stuff.
- How many kids would you want?
- Three.
- Ooh, she knows!
- Yeah, I grew up with a family of five,
and I like that little size,
I think it's a good size.
Awesome.
- All right, thank you!
It was nice talking to you.
- Yeah!
Well, thanks for chitchatting.
- Yeah, of course. It
was nice to meet you.
- You too.
- You look lovely by the way.
- Oh, thank you!
(all cheering)
- Dog!
- You know me a flirt in the back,
that boy spit the most game!
I be like dang!
- [Al] Ryan, bro.
- What did I do?
- All the little flirtation.
- Y'all, I'm telling y'all
I was not flirting at all.
(lowkey music)
- They all seem really
genuine, so I trust them.
- Oh my god, hi!
- What's good?
- I'll give you a hug.
Hi.
- Yep.
- How are you feeling?
- I'm good. I mean, I'm
definitely happy with the outcome.
- Yeah, I'm happy too actually.
- Are you?
- You're like super nice and
easy to talk to, so, yeah.
(laughs)
- I'm just kidding.
- Yeah he's super nice!
- Thank you.
- [All The Men] Ooh.
- Round two? Okay.
I picked Jether.
(all laughing)
- [One Of The Men] Yo!
- I'm just kidding.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
- I picked Jether.
(all surprised)
- [One Of The Men] Oh my god, no!
- Only because I really like his style,
and then I thought we had
a really good conversation,
but I would like to exchange
numbers with you too, so...
- Okay.
- I was back there, it
was them two that I was
talking about, so, worked
out perfectly I think.
- All three of us?
(all cheering)
- [One Of The Men] Let's go!
- Yeah, I think separately.
Yeah, okay, yeah.
- I feel cool. If it wasn't
him, then it had to be me.
(all jeering)
- It's facts, straight facts.
- I mean, I voted for him.
- I voted for him too.
(all clapping)
- [Interviewer] Thank you to Mabel.
- Of course.
(all laughing)
- [Interviewer] All right,
thank you guys so much!